[Music]
thank you
welcome to star talk live at the keswick
theater
all right
i am neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and i always do this with
a co-host my co-host tonight is going to
be and is chuck nice chuck where are you
man
[Applause]
[Laughter]
what's up buddy
what's up philly
some of you know chuck is a philly
native that's right
born and bred philadelphia that's why i
know we're not actually in philadelphia
you know but it you know it doesn't
really work when you walk out like
what's up clinton
yeah that wouldn't work
that that wouldn't work uh so
chuck yeah man so i i think we're in
philadelphia
it's very cool you know star talk is
about science right i did not know that
so i thought to myself
let's
talk about
like
a cool
important interesting
scientist
who we associate with philadelphia
will smith
is he from philadelphia he is from
philly west philadelphia born and raised
from what i hear
and uh
he's a slapologist
[Laughter]
no
no no no no
we're going to talk about
perhaps
philadelphia's most famous scientist
which many other people think of him as
just a founding father of course we're
talking about
benjamin
franklin all right
so
let's get started so chuck what do you
know about benjamin franklin oh man i
know he's got a parkway
i know he's got a bridge
i know he got an institute
i know he's on a hundred dollar bill
exactly oh man uh yeah that it's all you
look at this like you've never seen 100
do we not pay you enough
let me tell you something this is you
just
i can't even talk anymore
that's how much i love money and ben
franklin
yeah
no so that's that's good so
we know we associate him at least in the
scientific community with his
discoveries on electricity of course
okay and
electricity and lightning
i got a lot to say about lightning
people think they understand lightning
but
usually they don't even if they think so
because you know lightning
strikes from the ground up
not from the clouds to the ground did
you know that yeah tell that to the
every greek painting that i've seen
but what else uh ben frank was a printer
okay that's right and he printed and
people don't know this chuck you come
from a printer family and every printer
in the world loves ben franklin i love
brent franklin because my father was a
printer and if it weren't for ben
franklin i would have starved as a child
no but you but you worked in the
printing factory with him with my dad
yes and i actually ran something called
a raised letter press which is what he
pretty much invented yeah okay all right
and ben frank was also a successful
businessman he
uh so there's so many things and i don't
have particular expertise on this okay
i'm just saying so we gotta we we gotta
do this star talk style and we coned the
landscape
for an expert on benjamin franklin you
know where we landed at the yale library
which is undergoing a multi-year project
to collect the complete papers
of benjamin franklin wow so we got the
editor-in-chief of that project here
today please give a warm philly welcome
to ellen cohen editor-in-chief of the
benjamin franklin
papers
[Applause]
please have a seat
ellen
this is what makes this show so great
we just cheered for a librarian
that's a there's nothing better in the
world than that okay
except here's the thing
i'm not a librarian okay like i said
we just cheer for editor-in-chief yeah
so let me ask you ellen you're
editor-in-chief of this project
um
benjamin frank was prolific so this
means it's a big project
and how long have you been at this
okay sorry okay
no how i mean how long what how do we
how
long uh since i was in diapers yeah okay
yeah no we're talking 40 years
40 years yes and that got you through
how far in his life well look here's the
thing we started our project back in
1954
and the idea was to collect every single
thing that we could find around the
world that benjamin franklin wrote
and also everything that he received
so it's both sides of the correspondence
and um
you know when he invented lightning
we're only like in volume four
and i just handed in volume 44 to the
yale press
um it
thank you it was a really tough volume
and there's so um in all they're going
to be 47.
i mean this guy was amazing and
about half of those volumes
covers the period when he was in france
during the revolution
um
and so how much of that did you uh i
mean we think of him as a founding
father and nowhere on the hundred dollar
bill is there any oh sorry
is there any indication that he was a
scientist
so what percent of his papers and his
body of work
is reflected reflects his
capacity as a scientist in all of that
correspondence well you know here's the
amazing thing about him is that his
entire life he was interested in science
um he was so curious about everything
that he saw
as any good scientist should be
okay so like it's not like you're gonna
find too many scientists they're like
what's that
[Laughter]
like just to give you an example
how many people of his day or how many
of you have ever sat in a darkened room
with a fire going in the fireplace
and there's a candle on the table
now benjamin franklin noticed that the
smoke from that candle was traveling in
a certain direction
and he thought huh that's interesting
and he made it his business to try to
find out why i mean that's the kind of
guy he was his entire oh so it was a lit
candle yes i'm sorry i did like why
would the candle start floating in the
air okay so he's saying normally the
smoke of a candle goes straight up he's
got a fireplace going
and now the smoke is going towards the
fire
so he notices this and asks
himself what's going on what's going on
that's a that's a an observant curious
person yeah yes because all i would have
thought is why am i here alone
[Laughter]
this setting is very very sexy
wait so he didn't so it's something i
didn't i never knew i know a little bit
about ben but did he he didn't study
science in school so here's the thing
this kid
um
was the 15th
child oh
in a family of 17 children wow
his poor mother
his poor mothers
mothers well that is to say healing
first of all
i don't need you bringing that kind of
stuff into my school system
[Laughter]
[Applause]
next thing you'll be up here talking
about your ben franklin critical race
theory
[Laughter]
i don't think she meant he was raised by
two mothers i'm pretty sure that's not
the yeah that's it oh my goodness
gracious i walked right into that one
well so
i i don't know if you know i've um
i have some expertise in the fabric of
the space-time continuum did you know
this
yes yeah yeah uh you did did you know
this too
okay
so also i have a watch
[Laughter]
so there
so
i was experimenting on this and
i was
able to open a portal through time
right
and i got
benjamin franklin
i'm starting to get a little worried to
be honest right now
because what i know is neil does not
smoke marijuana
so
so i brought him through
and then
i said why don't i just bring him here
and so then i got in an uber
and he
didn't
and so i lost him
neil and ben's not so excellent
adventure
[Laughter]
because that i would be fun if we had
ben franklin here but so but i don't
know where he is he's wandering the
streets of philadelphia
yeah well here's what you don't know
i would think that that was like a
fantastical story
except that
i actually found ben franklin
i found him standing on the street just
staring at some electrical wires
and then when i asked him what are you
doing he was like i'm not looking at the
wires
this is philly
i'm looking at them shoes
why would anybody put shoes up on the
wire
was it a typewritten artist who fell
and that is all that is left of him
what exactly happened here
a tightrope artist yeah that wow yeah i
never thought to think that yeah but if
i came from another time yeah that's
what i you might think of that yeah
right yeah but really it's just some
brother walking around without sneakers
because he ran into the wrong people in
philly
[Laughter]
the only city where they don't steal
your shoes
they throw them up on the wire
so that you can look at them every day
yeah man those are my shoes
wait can we get back to ben franklin
okay
wait so you so i'm serious about ben
frank did you bring him here
where i thought by now he'll ben
franklin
ben
ben
[Laughter]
you're very kind benjamin franklin it
was just an uber i was getting into you
didn't have to be afraid of it just
wandered off i
i you left me just standing there can we
get van a chair please do we have
don't guide how do we do ellen it's nice
to see you thank you good to see you
again ben good to see you how are you
i'm very well i'm excellent well you're
very kind to us nice to see you all my
friends good evening
thank you you're very kind
you're too kind
so ben neil did you got a chance to see
phil what do you think of philadelphia
today
why don't we take my money i thought
that would happen i'm sorry you don't
even know what this is
time is money um
that is legal tender ben with your face
on it
did he not he said it had my face on it
i think yeah it's totally there on your
face um yeah so tell me what do you
think of philly today
it's enormous it's wonderful how much
it's expanded um when i had come to
philadelphia
as a runaway from boston it was this
town of only maybe six thousand five
thousand six thousand people 1776
philadelphia had become the largest city
in the new colonies um perhaps with
60 000 people perhaps at most uh it was
only at that time i think at that time
there was only one city in the world
with over a million people that would be
beijing london perhaps was well on its
way but i've certainly never seen a city
with millions and millions of people
together and back then did the traffic
suck as much as it does now the traffic
the the roads were in terrible condition
during the pennsylvania convention while
we were we had to cover all the roads
with gravel because it was making the
the carriage wheels would make so much
noise on the cobblestone and it was a
tripping hazard you don't want to be in
a cobblestone city so ben you were a
successful printer in fact from what
i've read you were quite wealthy
so is that wealth
give you
free time to then do cool science things
because i don't think anyone was paying
you to do science
that is true no that was would be the
purview of a gentleman i you're
absolutely right i did have some success
uh with my printing specifically with my
almanac did very well um poor richard
richards almanac and it's wait let me
ask now who the hell is poor richard
well poor richard is a character
franklin made up
he uh in philadelphia
he i mean he just had to make a buck he
had to make a living and he saw that
almanacs sold really well
and so he wanted to make one himself
and he in fact was such a cutthroat
competitor
his almanac was funnier
wittier it just obliterated the
competition because
he created this character called
richard saunders poor richard
and richard saunders in the preface to
the first almanac says kind reader uh
i'm an honest fellow but i got this wife
back home who's really
like hammering on me to make more money
and so to please her i'm doing this
almanac because i know they sell really
well
and i never ever would have done this
if it hadn't been for the fact that
titan leads
the other almanac maker in town far more
popular than me at the time
uh that titan leads we know from
predictions in the almanac that he's
going to die on a certain day
wow
and he also because he's a great
predictor of things he also knows he's
going to die on a certain date but but
we differ about which day it's going to
be
and so although i'm a good friend of his
i thought maybe now's the time for me to
get into it
well
titan leads had no intention of dying
and when he read that he went
nuts
and he went hopping around town saying
i'm not
unlike you i'm not dead
i'm not dead and
there was such excitement and franklin
just out maneuvered him in every way and
before you know it his
leads just folded and his almanacs flew
off the shelf but here's a connection to
science
as soon as franklin's almanacs became
really popular
he was able to add more pages to them
because everybody
everybody was buying them
and what did he do
he starts putting articles in there
about science
he took he took articles that had come
over from london and he would reprint
them in the almanac because it wasn't
enough for him to learn about these
amazing things he wanted to educate
everybody about them so what is the
junto society does that have well so
after um after having published the
almanac for a number of years at the age
of 42 i was able to retire and sell my
business and i would never have to work
again and this is when i had begun
at age 42 at age 42. wow and this is
when i began the pursuit seriously of
science but um but earlier i had been in
london when i was 19 and i had seen
other clubs the tiff club the tuesday
club and i had created a club when i was
a working man in philadelphia called the
junto with other like-minded working men
eventually we were joined by ship's
captains and together junto of course
being um
uh in latin for um joined together junta
they assist
join together they assist and so
together with the junto with this club
of like-minded people we were able to
better ourselves better our community
and eventually we together founded um
the first uh library uh subscription
library here in america which still
exists today and the first science
academy the american philosophical
society which still exists in your day i
was recently inducted as a member
congratulations
society in fact they are based here in
philadelphia and that's how i felt
they told me
neil is like the black ben franklin
no
so
so
but well they have a number of my um
little improvements and my of course
rattle traps what i'm asking is you you
create this you create that and at no
time have we yet even talked about ben
franklin as a diplomat and that's how
most of anyone thinks about you as a
founding father so how did you have time
for all of this uh time machine time
is um it requires um concentration and a
schedule i have um a certain
mathematical
attitude towards time just as i have to
everything
i
for instance if one wants to live a good
and virtuous life one must
create a moral compass or moral algebra
if one is to have enough time to do
everything one wishes to accomplish uh
must one must a lot the time and one
must devote the time to it and so i
created a very rigid schedule which for
the most part until much later in my
life i stuck to and allowed myself
to wake at a certain time to prepare my
letters at a certain time to devote a
certain amount of time i also became i
believe that the translation of what ben
is trying to say is
we did not have the internet yeah
or netflix right right or netflix at
night and we certainly did not chill
ever
but nothing is done in a vacuum we are i
am working alongside me and i'm inspired
by so many greater men and working
alongside so many other great minds
so so ellen from your records
um when did ben transition from
the bringer of science to people to the
doer of
science when was that
well
one of the first
um
one of the first
things that he did in
uh in a scientific realm in america i
think
was uh
if you don't know we can find out
because he said right
of the transit is that what you're
thinking well go ahead no no please
please you've read my letters more
recently than i have
[Laughter]
no talk about the transit
well the transit of venus i actually
deal you probably do indeed the transit
of venus is very important did you have
you probably had a chance to study it in
your life yes so venus
twice every couple of hundred years
will move between earth's
vista on the sun and the sun itself
and that when observed from different
parts of the earth enable you to
triangulate and get a precise distance
to venus
when you do that
it allows you to get the full
measurement of the entire solar system
where the distances to all the planets
because previously you got distances
just in units of the earth's sun
distance but you didn't know exactly how
how far that was exactly so everything
was in unit of earth sun but the transit
of venus transforms that
and you would have seen the transit of
venus in the so 1780s is that well so in
1761 we have one and unfortunately i'm
not able to see it but we begin to see
it studied also in 1761 there's war
taking place that's going to interfere
but i think it's in 1769
that we are able to participate globally
so we have mason and dixon studying it
yeah we have
david rittenhouse creating a telescope
and studying not far from here in
northern we and i'm in fact i'm in a um
we build an observatory just behind the
pennsylvania state house and some years
later the declaration of independence
will be read out loud from that same
platform where we will
track and study and time the transit of
venus in order to come up with this
final number that will finally give us
the um the distance between the sun
and the earth yeah and we came up with
the number of
90 million miles
that was so wrong it's 93. yeah it's 93
million miles we were very wrong
get back to the drawing board
and correct your life has been wasted
there's an absolute
failure we take our first break let me
just bring this to it i think an
interesting close
that transit of venus was also viewed
by
captain cook captain on an expedition
from england
and that was best viewed
that was best viewed from
the south pacific and so
england says
go to this captain cook
go to the south pacific hear new tools
to measure the transit of venus oh by
the way
by the way could you map every coastline
you see
whatever landmass you had to give it
just just just on the side go ahead and
do that
he measures the transit of venus
brilliantly comes back to england
presents the maps
of australia new zealand the i the cook
islands all of this and within decades
england takes ownership of those land
masses
just take a look at all the flags
of those countries
okay half of them have the union jack
inserted in it that's traceable
many of them do still have they learned
nothing
[Laughter]
we're going to take a quick break when
we come back we're going to delve deeper
into
professor franklin's scientific career
on start talk live at the keswick
theater
[Applause]
all right we're back keswick theater
star talk live
we're outside of philadelphia
and who better to talk about is one of
its finest most significant citizens of
the past and i would say even the
present day is spirit energy remains
with us in this part of the world and i
would say
around the world
itself you're very kind benjamin
franklin give up for
franklin
and of course ellen cohn who is the
editor-in-chief of the benjamin franklin
papers project which has been conducted
out of the yale library yes
so ben let's talk about your most famous
experiment
which i as a kid didn't understand and i
still don't fair enough what's up with
you and a kite
and a key oh yes electricity what the
hell were you doing why why who what
don't you know
that's it's dangerous oh i do know that
it's i didn't that's why i did not fly
the um kite in the in the storm my um
i i had i stood in a little paddock and
my son william flew the oh
if you're
if you're going to perform the year
there that's it if you're going to
perform a dangerous um experiment may i
always suggest um placing your progeny
in they they
can't sue you
mostly because they can't sue you
so what was your what was your objective
there
so um
so we're working with the american
philosophical society we're doing
experiments i have retired and i am
corresponding with a friend in england
at the royal society peter collinson and
he sends me a wonderful new invention
from the university of leyden leiden
known as leiden jar normally these sort
of inventions these innovations would
have been
named after the creator but in this case
the creator was a professor musselbach i
don't think anyone's going out and
buying a musselbach jar so we called it
a leiden jar and he saw he so peter
sends me one of these and he says
perhaps you'd like to consider
understanding how it works learn how it
functions and we begin
by
uh very would you like to describe what
well so the lightning
as i remember from my physics training
it's a jar
that's sort of electrically insulated
from what's around it but there are
metal sheets inside of it that
that if they become charged they just
sort of resist each other and you see
them just sort of separated sitting
there perfectly happy separated that's
kind of opposite what gravity would
otherwise have them do
so in a way it has trapped electricity
in this volume that's right and what i'm
going to do is take a dozen of them uh
18 and put them in a box and wire them
all together and create instead of just
producing electricity electrical fluid
by rubbing a piece of wool on a glass
tube
i'm going to create an electrostatic
generator an enormous machine and now
i'm going to have rows so imagine if you
will rows and rows of these jars all
sticking up i won't take your water just
imagine and now i can store
quantities of the electrical fluid in it
and it is rows and rows of these jars
sticking out of a box as if to me it
appears like a row of fouling pieces or
cannons sticking out of the top of a
balustrade and do you know what we call
that
a battery
a cannon sticking out of a balustream a
battery a battery yes and that is what
we're going to do we're going to try an
inventor and name
the battery okay and we're going to once
again fail um but it is to it's
got to start somewhere but it's going to
inspire me to perform
i don't know well in 130 separate
experiments
and eventually it will lead us to the
understanding that the electric will
lead us to many understandings it will
lead us to most importantly it will give
us a vocabulary a language a
nomenclature for studying this new
fluid
so so is that why you needed the kite
and the key well so ultimately the kite
in the key is going to prove the final
experiment which is that one form of
this electrical fluid is the discharge
of lightning and we're going to take
some electrical um uh
uh
from the sky not from a lightning bolt
that would be in lunacy
and we're going to put it into one of
these capacitors
we're going to take it back to our
laboratory we're going to perform a
series of experiments with it just how
quickly can it burn a piece of paper how
quickly can it and then we'll take
another battery filled with electrical
fluid created from
a
generator and it will perform exactly
the same way therefore we will prove
that these two seemingly different
substances are in fact the exact same
thing and at any time in this experiment
does it get you back to the future
apparently so
i would have said no
so just to put us on the same page
uh every time it rains anywhere in the
world
there are electrons that used to be up
in the sky in the clouds that have
arrived on earth
and electricity doesn't like being
imbalanced that way
all right these are from ions that come
out of the the the rain-swelled skies
and so the electrons collect now if you
happen to be under a
thunderstorm
there be a lot of those electrons
collecting locally the electrons want to
get back to the cloud
but they're really lazy
okay
and the last thing it wants to do
is move through air
because air is actually an electrical
insulator
all right it hates moving through the
air
so
when you build up enough charge
the chargers look around and say wait a
minute
i see a human being let me go up into
the human being now i have
five and a half less feet i have to move
through the air oh wait a minute there's
a tree let's go higher up
okay
there's less air that i have to move to
wait a minute
there's a church steeple
let's go up to the tip of the church
steeple
and we will discharge there
and so lightning
there's a what's called a leader stroke
that is exploring
what
path between the sky and the ground
requires the least stress
on the movement of these electrons it
finds the path it's called a leader
stroke
and the moment that liter stroke
completes the electrons surge back to
the cloud and that is the lightning bolt
that we all see that most people think
comes from the cloud to the ground
but it's the electrons that had
accumulated going from the ground
back up to the clouds now so you died
because of a bunch of lazy electrons
right so if you're the tallest one in an
area
you are susceptible okay
any time lightning
hits
a baseball game who does it hit
the tallest one
no we can do better than that
the pitcher
the picture is just a little bit closer
on the pitcher's mound and
that leader stroke
the moment it comes down you actually
will feel the static electricity so if
they if you feel your hair rising up
because you start accumulating these
extra charges if you start feeling the
hair rise up on your skin
drop to the ground immediately
because what's happening is the
electrons are gathering and they're
ready to make that
jump they're ready to jump but if you
drop low in that instant
then you will confound this exercise oh
my god where do we go
you know i'm just sitting here trying to
be a lazy electron
i don't understand
what just happened
so just a little bit of elec and by the
way when they launch rockets
you ever notice there's the launch pad
in the middle and there are four towers
multiple towers is a water tower as well
for other reasons but there are four
towers
that compete
with the rocket to attract lightning so
if lightning cut is if the electrons are
ready to come up and go back to a cloud
the rocket is not their first choice
because we've supplied them with a way
to go back and this reminds me of one
professor franklin's most brilliant
inventions
the lightning rod yeah yeah dude
so you did good there thank you and in
fact i i ellen would know better than i
there is a french natural philosopher
who is able to attract charges during a
bright sunshine
we see at the time that i'm in france
the italian uh seniore uh volta
um expanding on these ideas
yeah so the italians the electricity
is
has an imprint
of all the people who were
fundamental to its progress so alexander
volta
is a uh
the vault his name after him not the
chevy car i'm talking about
the vaults of your battery there's
ampere amps come from i think emperor's
french ampere so all of these names and
terms come there's even a
uh there's a faraday
there's a um
uh
but all these words we have for
electricity like you were saying
professor the doctor was taken i was
never a professor okay you could just
probably bend bam just bad as we were
saying ben
that i can't call you ben that's two
they behind my back the other um members
of the constitutional convention called
me doctor fat sides
really
they were
so with um lightning rod
you now give the
electrons a place to depart earth
so that they don't randomly find some
other thing like a church steeple and
destroy the church to people and in
boston they kept tearing down the
lightning rods for fear that i was they
believed from the pulpit suggesting that
i was somehow um creating an
accumulation of electrical fire i i left
something out excuse me so please the
lightning rod is so brilliant
it was it may have been more brilliant
than ben
knew
because watch what happens
so you have the lightning rod which is
just a piece of metal sticking up and
it's the highest point of your structure
all right so the electrons gather
if you make the lightning rod a point
this is important then
the electrons
on going to that point ready to go to
the cloud they'll leak off
and they'll just sort of drizzle off
into the sky
so lightning rods not only reduce the
chance
you'll get struck by lightning
if you're struck by lightning
it saves you from destruction but this
was a very important argument at the
time people the debate over a dull
topped lightning rod versus a point a
very sharp point was something we took
very all the electrons crowding there
they spill out it's very crowded and and
you can spill electrons back and
basically
never have the lightning strike that
would have otherwise taken place it's
just brilliant
now let me let me ask you ellen i'd
heard this and i just i just want
verification i want to see if you have
it
before the lightning rod by the way this
is the
1760s 70s what's the tallest structure
in any city in colonial america
church okay so what structure is most
likely to be hit by lightning first
church so
if there's a church here and a church
there and a church there
and that church gets hit by a lightning
i got a story
in my church right they say that was the
false church people yep that was the
false guys clearly god didn't like your
church didn't like your church
good way for me to get more church goers
into my church by holding that argument
but then ben comes along
and saves all the churches i heard
that there was criticisms
i don't know if it was heresy
of ben
thwarting the will of god
right
which is why we had to help it along
with something called jesus arson
jesus arson
because ben put up these lightning rods
these churches aren't burning down
and god told me to just burn your church
down
what so
so that was not my intention
wait so ben
so
for me the idea that you would be
accused of heresy for thwarting the will
of god i'm thinking to myself
how powerful is the god you're
worshiping
if mr fatso can prevent them from
destroying your church
this is my thought so do is there any
correspondence related to this oh he he
got immense criticism
um from people all over america and
europe too
um
most people believed that lightning was
god of course divine was divine
not just not just in modern religion but
you go back to ancient religions zeus
and you know
and and um did thor wield the lightning
bolt of just a hammer no thor called on
lightning he called down lightning with
his hammer with his hammer okay thank
you yeah and i got that from marvel
[Laughter]
now you know what else
inside churches throughout europe
uh there wasn't just people inside there
you know what else they used to store in
churches
uh the parts of dead saints
gun powder
oh that's smart
yeah you know that place that just keeps
catching fire for some reason more than
any other place you know what we said
let's put some gun powder there
well just uh only what 20 years before i
was born 20 years or so 30 years was the
great fire of london uh 1666 not too
long so this is what do you think about
dynamite
no because these dynamite was invented
by alfred nobel much later
so okay i don't spend that much time
clearly i did not know that
it's where he made his money to leave
the trust that would give the nobel
prizes
yeah dynamite tnt that's that's somewhat
disturbing to be honest yeah yeah that
the man who created the stuff that blows
things up
also made the peace prize
you have to give a prize for peace
yeah unfortunately yeah we need that
otherwise it's unfortunate there may be
even less incentive than there otherwise
would be
to create peace in the world
um but ben i want to before you take a
break i want to get to your other
experiments but tell me what other
critiques that were handed down well um
one of the ways that franklin countered
this argument
was to say
uh you know
god sends rain
and that doesn't keep us from putting
roofs over our heads brilliant
um that was good
that was good look at him he said yeah
that was me no i was thinking you made
me i love it he was like that was me
i don't remember how clever i was
it sounds even better with ellen tiles
in the middle of the summer time the sun
is really strong that doesn't prevent us
from carrying parasols
so why should it be
that if the deity gives us the knowledge
to um
understand
these phenomena
then why
shouldn't we take advantage of that
knowledge to protect ourselves i'll tell
you why because the next thing you'll be
telling me is that i need to get
vaccinated okay
that's why
as a man
wait wait ben what's this oil and water
thing you did
ellen
would you would you like to tell them
about a bead of water spreading out
yeah so here's the thing
even from the earliest age franklin uh
being the observant kid he was and young
man as he was crossing the ocean back
and forth he noticed that when the cooks
dumped the cooking oil overboard
the waves smoothed out
why is that why is that he kept on
thinking about it and much later when he
was living in england he thought
he was talking to people about this
phenomenon and he said i'm going to do
an experiment
he took a little bit of oil
and he carried it to a pond
and
uh thank you
and
he put the oil on the surface of the
pond on a windy day
to see what would happen
and to his amazement because no one ever
expected this the oil
smoothed out the water it became
smoothest glass but it didn't stop there
that smooth area kept
going and going and going until
to everybody's amazement
half an acre of water
was
absolutely flat
and so covered by a tiny bit of oil
introduced to then a teaspoon full of
oil
he would have loved exxon
well but you know in our time there was
practical applications for this um
oyster divers would put a little bit of
oil and it would allow them to see
their catch oh because otherwise the
turbulent water disrupts the optics yes
of what's below when i first heard this
i say what oh
i get it all right so if you ever
freshly wax a car
and you put a bead of water on it it
just sort of stays there sort of propped
up
all right so that's called surface
tension
and so water has pretty good surface
tension it'll just sort of stay there as
a bead you put too much water there
it'll spill off but just a little bit
water will stay as a bead
if you
do that with oil
oil has
very low surface tension so it won't
beat up
you put the oil there it'll just spread
it's like a lazy electron
it'll just spread
and what we would learn
after the fact because of this brilliant
experiment because it's not only what do
you see that intrigues you it's what do
you do
that creates more things to be intrigued
by
that the oil
under the right conditions would spread
to one molecule thick
and so you can calculate
the size of the molecule based on the
volume of your teaspoon and how much
area it ended up covering it was it's
just brilliant
and that was the experiment that was
done based on franklin's observations
and his writing up that experiment
at his time they didn't understand the
composition of a molecule they didn't
have the word for
molecule i don't know but
not long not long after he died he had
elements but you didn't have atoms atoms
were not understood yeah
yeah and so that was the seminal
experiment that got other people
thinking about how that could be used to
measure
the thickness of a molecule ben this
requires very high standards of
measurement of uh
and you have to be careful about your
own bias that could influence the result
because then someone else will check
your results and if you find out you
didn't
take the notes right that would look bad
on your reputation so right so well
there's nothing more inspiring than when
you have an experiment that fails but
can inspire another scientist to improve
upon what's more inspiring than that is
doing experiment that succeeds oh well
clearly i have very little experience
with that no no but but you're
absolutely
the null experiment
can make a very interesting starting
point for others so
given your
that you're in it
you're doing it
what
what did you have tolerance for
i don't know what word you might have
had in the day today we would call it
pseudoscience where people in denial of
science people who did not see care or
appreciate what the scientific methods
would do
did you have any sense of that there's
so much of this and of course you must
understand we're living in an age where
new ideas are being introduced and it's
sometimes very hard to determine
which ideas are true or not i can not
think of what can you think of an
example of a pseudoscience from my age
what was your attitude towards it let me
ask that oh
not good
okay well a perfect example we mentioned
the almanacs i'm trying to all of the
calculations i did for my astronaut for
my astronomical um
right
sun moon and stars i'm doing all of that
well and also we would do mercury rise
okay we i worked closely with uh
scientists who started to um study and
trace uh what would eventually become
known as uranus um and this uranus we
say you'll learn this thank you yeah
anus you're right uranus uranus
the discovery would come later but but
no i the um but this of course was why
we would need a library to have these
um to have these
i mean it comes back over and over to
plenty to uh to play an early
documentary of all knowledge yes
newton who i never had a chance to meet
but would have been
in my time in these great inspirations
um these are doing the best science when
we fail
we hope to inspire others when we see
people who are simply
projecting their own bias or their own
religious beliefs like the idea that
electricity gathered with a lightning
rod will cause earthquakes
that would be a pseudo science of my age
that was very common interesting well
here's an example
there was a guy during franklin's
lifetime who published an article saying
i've invented a pair of shoes
that can allow me to walk across the
river sand
now
that seemed to be easy to test yeah
i'm just thinking you don't need a grant
from the national science foundation by
the way
if you buy those shoes you deserve to be
ripped off
and maybe even drown
well you know society was filled with
people who were trying to make money off
of a uneducated
credulous public and that was one of the
reasons why franklin at every turn
tried not only to do his own experiments
and hold himself to those kind of
standards you're talking about
but also educate other people so that
they wouldn't fall prey to the kind of
nonsense
that
sounded good if you said it with the
right kind of authority
he
hated that yeah none of that happens
today no really
but at the same time imagine for example
that someone tells you that they have
recently witnessed a man
leave the earth
and float six seven thousand miles
feet six thousand seven thousand feet
above the city of paris
yeah that might seem
um unlikely and yet this was something i
witnessed in my lifetime the first hot
air balloon so we are living in a time
of what's a little different than a man
floating up from the ground no it's
really sorry ben i'm just letting you
know it's it's lighter than air it is
yeah but it's a balloon
like it's still a balloon the first time
you see it like no if you just took off
flying right now i'd be like whoa
that is something but if you jump in a
balloon i'll be like oh look at that
he's in a balloon but you've never seen
a balloon before oh well except as a toy
a child okay that makes sense yeah yeah
so when the bank office i forgot you've
been dead a long time
we all have seen balloons but
nobody here is impressed by a balloon
so ellen what you're saying not to put
words in your mouth you're saying in
that time there's a lot of
challenges and issues
communicating objective scientific truth
to a public that is otherwise gullible
in many ways and that's kind of no
different from what we're seeing today
yes today we call it uh the nigerian
prince
hi i just need some money that you can
give me for just a little bit and then i
will give you back 10 times as much wait
wait
chuck weren't those in emails from 20
years ago
no it was the email from tuesday
all right we're going to take a quick
break and when we come back we're going
to find out what ben was doing in france
during the revolutionary war when star
talk live from the keswick theater
continues
[Applause]
we're back star talk live keswick
theater
i got chuck nice my co-host i've got
ellen cohen
editor-in-chief of the benjamin franklin
papers project up at yale in new haven
and we've got none other than ben
franklin himself thank you ben
[Applause]
so we know
that
the american colonies
were very friendly with france
through jefferson and through the
diplomacy of ben franklin and
of course while we're fighting england
the french are always looking for a good
fight against england anyway
so they were sympathizers to our cause
and very shortly after our revolution
they had theirs right so so my ask you
what brought ben to france and what was
he doing there while
while in residence
well actually it was not at all a given
that france was going to help the
american colonies
not at all we are not sure if we want to
help you colonists
you do not have the hard french soap you
smell like peasants
does every french person you imitate
smoke a cigarette this is what we do we
were bombed with cigarettes in our hands
okay
continue never mind chuck on the corner
there okay go
so um
when uh
the patriots gathered
and wrote the declaration of
independence
and pledged that they would risk their
lives on this cause the question was
how are we going to win this war i mean
it's one thing to declare a war it's
another thing to fight a war when you
don't have guns you don't have
ammunition you don't have any place to
go and buy tools the colonies
relied on england for everything and now
all of a sudden not only do they declare
their independence they're cut off from
their supplier
so
they
sent benjamin franklin to france to try
to persuade the king of france
to support a revolution against another
king now that was not going to play
necessarily because kings kind of like
yo kings rule with kings
we'll recognize real
so
why did they choose franklin to do this
mission that was in fact not at all a
sure thing the reason was that by the
time
77
1776 rolled around
he was already by far the most famous
man in america why because of his
lightning experiments science his
science
and it wasn't just
that the lightning rod was saved
millions of lives and it wasn't just
that he invented the battery
most people considered the most
significant thing about his experiments
to be
that he proved
that
something that was invisible in the
atmosphere was actually electricity
no one had any concept of that before he
came along and proved it with the kite
in the key so his legacy preceded him in
europe yes
he was immediately made a member of the
royal society which was the greatest
scientific organization in england
and
he was made and this was astonishing
because the french don't do this very
often they made him
a member of the french academy of
science the academy francaise
wow so he was
when he arrived now congress sent him
over to france in top secret he was on a
ship that if it had been captured he
would have been hanged
so no one had any idea that he was
actually on that ship and when he set
foot on french soil the french went
nuts
um because they already knew who he was
and they loved him so it was his science
scientific reputation
i did not know that so are you telling
me
that if we sent neil degrasse tyson on a
secret mission to talk
to vladimir putin
[Laughter]
that there could be a possibility yeah
that we might be able to get something
done yeah
okay this is very encouraging i did this
is beautiful and brilliant and i i
i'm deeply moved by this fact that
science
in the day would be elevated to become
something even greater than diplomacy
itself
because it sailed above
popularity contests or anything else of
the seizing of power
it recognized
brilliance and that gives us deep hope i
think yeah and let me tell you something
else that's totally inspiring
um you mentioned before about captain
cook yes
well after that voyage they sent him
back
you remember this yeah he had multiple
voyages yeah yeah and until he didn't
well that's
but i was in hawaii once and i was what
don ho
okay that's how old i am i was watching
donahoe and someone asked him at the end
that what happened to captain cook
and donjon said
i don't know
haven't seen him in a while
rumors are that he was eaten by he was
he was yeah okay so here's the thing
during the war during the american
revolution captain cook uh well actually
they didn't know it in london but he had
already been in put in the pot uh but
the rest of his boats the rest of his
ships somebody had captain cook for
dinner yes
but the rest of it but his ships
[Laughter]
sorry that was low-hanging fruit i had
to say
somebody had captain cook for dinner
and they enjoyed it yeah we heard it the
first time yeah okay
sorry ellen we'll shut up please
continue well
uh
so
word reached
uh europe
that captain cook's ships were on their
way back from this voyage of exploration
and discovery
and franklin was our ambassador in
france
he couldn't communicate with congress
there was no way to do that a letter
might take
six weeks to go
and six weeks to come back he had to act
on his own so when he found out that
cook ships were traveling north
he issued on his own initiative an order
to every single american captain sailing
on the ocean
leave those ships alone not only leave
them alone but if you meet with captain
cook ships
now keep in mind these are british ships
and by rights
any american would have been authorized
to seize them
franklin said leave them alone in fact
give them any assistance that they might
require because
they're on a mission a scientific
mission
and science should be in a plane above
politics
when word reached the royal society in
england that franklin had done this
still in the middle of the war i mean
the war was like at its height
the royal society voted to give him a
gold medal
and the british the
british admiral the head of the british
admiralty wrote him a letter and sent it
to him
um
and you can just imagine
uh what this meant to him
yeah i mean if the world recognizes your
work
that goes beyond just whatever
satisfaction you'd get
recognizing yourself
so just congratulations i'm far too
humble to
but wait but that wasn't it didn't stop
there
europe turned dark
in seventeen
for mysterious reasons
this is while i'm in france in 1783 this
is the same time that we are writing the
treaty of paris the war will be coming
to an end soon
so
tell me what happened then
well it was this amazing
terrifying thing that happened
um in the summer of 1783
hadn't yet signed the treaty
the sky
all over europe turned dark
the sun was just this dim little uh uh
disc in the sky
when the sun said it was blood
red people were
terrified
that's something they got all biblical
probably right yeah yeah
that summer was super super super hot
there were
thunderstorms people were dying
livestock was dying nobody knew what and
god's name was going on
and that continued for months
into the next winter which
correspondingly was the coldest winter
on record
and so at a certain point i mean
scientists all over europe were
writing to each other trying to figure
out what caused this what's going on
here
and franklin
very tentatively
wrote
a letter a little essay which he called
meteorological conjectures
because he wasn't sure
but he analyzed the situation and he
said the sign of a good scientist is if
you don't really know for sure
you don't say that you know for sure and
the really good ones never say they're
sure certainly because then they can
never be wrong
[Laughter]
all right so what he said was he thought
that it was possible
that the particulate in the air was
actually ash and gases from a volcano in
iceland
that he had read a story telling him
that this huge explosion had happened
eruption
um and it turned out he was absolutely
right
uh and that happened just a few years
ago even 10 years ago yeah around there
yeah a volcano
same volcano the safe they had to stop
all air traffic yes the airplanes we
invented how to fly just so you know
okay
air balloons so because jet engines take
in air and if the air is filled with
dust from a
volcano that is bad yeah but
if you look at prevailing wind patterns
in the rotating earth
generally they move west to east that
happens in the united states it happens
over europe and i wonder how we
determined that that was happening in
the united states
remember how he said he's so humble i'm
sorry
i proved that uh whether appearing to
come to philadelphia from the north east
was in fact coming from the southwest
hence the nor'easter
term that i
sorry please continue
so so
i wouldn't even call that a good guess i
mean he had to really think through
what that is and what it meant and
arrive at that conclusion
ben what could you tell me about mesmer
friedrich mezra
yes so mesmer had been going anton anton
thank you anton mesmer was pretty good
too though
antoine mesmer anton friedrich oh
friedrich von steuben
so anton mesmer is going around uh
europe the continent claiming
um a new form of medical treatment which
will eventually become known as animal
magnetism this quality that rests within
us
and he can treat it and he has various
techniques and eventually he um this mes
this this abnormal magnetism can be
affected
he claims by a musical instrument that i
had invented
known as the glass harmonica
and eventually he finds his way to
france while i'm there as our minister
to france and i will let ellen take over
from this point and let you know what
happens when mesmer antoine mesmer and
his animal magnetism
begins to this is this this is the same
mesmer as the that what gave us the the
mesmerized
mesmeris mesmerizing that's the same
mesmer okay is part i know you can't
resist me this is the same the music is
very um well the music is incidental in
fact
please
i mean he used music but he then he
didn't use music here's the thing about
mesmer the reason he came to france
is because he was kicked out of vienna
this is a guy this was a doctor
who
gathered people around
turned off the lights
put
his patients right in front of them
stroked their thighs i'm not kidding you
uh and then he would look deep into
their eyes mesmerism
and then he would tell them
that whatever was ailing them he could
cure sounds like a human resources
problem
and
people believed him and folks flocked to
his clinic they believed it because they
wanted it to be true
well nobody understood that until he
claimed he could cure blindness
claimed he could cure all kinds of
things
and so he gets run out of vienna he
comes to paris sets up clinics
all these french people come
pay tons of money
they're all having symptoms and
twitching and god knows what
and
the government's getting really worried
about this guy
so
they
the king of france appoints a commission
of the greatest
scientists from the academy of sciences
and the greatest doctors from the
academy of medicine and they say you
gotta investigate this guy
now what's fast this is one of the most
important incidents in the history of
medicine
of the 18th century because just think
about it
nobody could see this magnetic fluid
and
they put benjamin franklin on the
commission you can understand why he was
the guy who had identified this
invisible force in the sky
now there's a doctor claiming there's
some invisible force that he can
manipulate
and only he knows the secret it's not
telling
so
how do you
like get at this how do you figure out
whether it's
true or not
and one of the most brilliant things
about this commission
was
they
they conferred they tried to think how
do we devise experiments to get at this
and
they came up with this idea
animal magnetism
uh
can exist
without being useful
but it cannot be useful
if it doesn't exist
so
the science
contingent said
before we do anything else we have to
see if we can prove
whether this invisible force
exists
and they did over the course of four
months a series of controlled
experiments that
are mind blowing and they wrote up a big
report that reads like a detective novel
it's so well written and you're just on
the edge of your chair
the one experiment
that was the one that clinched it that
animal magnetism didn't exist
they had a doctor who practiced
magnetism and he went and he magnetized
a tree apricot tree
yes in my garden in franklin's yard
and they said to the guy now you can
bring with you a patient you choose the
patient
uh and we're going to test using blind
photo
and see if he can
feel anything from the magnetized tree
this was a little boy 12 years old and
i don't think they were counting on the
fact
that
the kid would be blindfolded and that
when the doctor
magnetized the tree
they would be
the kid was like inside the house so
there could be no communication
well the kid with his blindfold
uh
went to the wrong tree and start shaking
and having convulsions and god knows
what anyway it was obvious that this was
a bunch of hooey the word it's [ __ ]
all
right
yes sorry excuse me
but here's the next part of the story
that is mind-blowing after they proved
that it didn't exist
it was franklin who had for almost all
of his life been thinking about how the
mind can affect sensations in the body
and so they devised a series of amazing
tests that we would call double-blind
experiments
where they had patients
think that they were being magnetized
when they weren't
they had patients sitting there not
knowing anything what was going on with
the doctor like shooting death rays adam
um
they did all kinds of variations and the
conclusion was
this thing worked if the patient
believed that it would work and this was
the moment in the history of science
when
uh what they called imagination they
said
animal magnetism doesn't exist
but it seems to be true that our own
minds are able to cause all kinds of
physical sensations in our body and this
led to
uh
what we call the placebo effect all
kinds of things like that this
i like that well they did the wrong
experiments if they wanted to know if
animal magnetism really existed all they
had to do was put chuck nice in a
cocktail party
how that works but this notion but this
is a very important notion because i
have tried in everything i have
endeavored to serve the benefit of
mankind and here we have an unscrupulous
doctor practicing what is clearly an
unscrupulous um technique but you
wouldn't have known that until you could
demonstrate it and have everyone else
convinced of it but what if it serves
some purpose what if it is useful for
some what if they believe themselves to
be i don't mind that but just don't call
it science
call it something else
so i'm going to summarize
if i may
that the life of ben franklin was not so
much enumerated experiments
his entire life
was an experiment
and
i'm reminded in
with the starkness of the detail here
just in in blunt detail
that
an experiment
is the boundary
between
what is known and unknown
in the universe
what is unknown and unknown for you
so
experiments are something to be
cherished something to be cultivated
something that we should continue our
entire lives lest we ossify in whatever
was the last course we took in school
and then you think that's the
understanding of reality
but reality is continually being
explored
by the likes of benjamin franklin in
modern times and we hope continuing into
the future yeah and the more people who
think that way and participate in that
exercise will transform civilization as
we know it because we need it because we
need to become better shepherds of our
own future that right now is driving off
a cliff
so
thank you all for coming this has been
star talk live at the keswick theater
thank you ellen cohn
chuck nice
excellent
mitchell cramer as benjamin franklin
ladies and gentlemen goodbye
all of you drive safely stay safe
as always keep looking up
[Music]